you
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen Farnum jahannum
president Carnegie Mellon University
[Applause]
well good afternoon okay we're going to
try this again good afternoon
Oh much better much better it is my
great pleasure to extend a warm welcome
to all of you as we kick off this
inaugural CMU K&L gates conference on
ethics and artificial intelligence
before I get started we pick this date
in April because we knew that this would
be the third week of spring and
especially for many of our friends and
colleagues from the Bay Area from the
west coast and from Texas we knew that
you wanted to enjoy spring in Pittsburgh
so you are welcome really happy to
welcome all of you on behalf of my
colleagues at Carnegie Mellon we're
joined here today by several of our
trustees and members of the university
leadership team and by a wide array of
distinguished CMU faculty and thought
leaders from across the country you will
hear from them throughout the day today
and tomorrow as one of Carnegie Mellon's
newest initiatives and annual traditions
this conference brings together thought
leaders from diverse perspectives to
discuss the ethical social and policy
ramifications brought on by advances in
artificial intelligence and
computational technologies this two-day
event has been made possible by an
exceptional coalition of support first I
want to take a moment to thank our
extraordinary partners at K&L Gates ever
since we began discussing the
possibility of this new forum I've been
impressed by the thought and foresight
of our K&L Gates partners
who understood the far-reaching the
effects of these new technologies not
only in the legal world but also
throughout society and they've been
willing to invest in work to make sure
that these technologies and these
unprecedented advances that we see
benefit society and benefits humanity
because of their generosity can all get
Endowment for Ethics and computational
technologies will advance research and
education in this critical domain and
foster dialogues like this week's
conference I'm delighted to welcome
several representatives from K&L gates
this afternoon including Jim Segura
Dahle global managing partner who will
provide remarks in just a few minutes
Michael Casas chairman of the management
committee and david lehman partner and
co head of the K&L gates
artificial intelligence initiative and i
should note that michael is also a proud
CMU alone dietrich a college class of 82
michael was 10 years old when he
graduated from college ladies and
gentlemen please join me in welcoming
and thanking all of our partners from
K&L gates
[Applause]
I'm also police to acknowledge all of
our conference speakers and panelists
including my friend Eric Horvitz
director of Microsoft Research Lab who
is here today as our distinguished
speaker for this event welcome Eric pre
praying such an extraordinary agenda
requires exceptional leadership so I'm
grateful to the conference organizers
the steering committee and of course my
colleagues the co-chairs David Danks and
Eleanor Bach
finally this conference has been
supported by countless professionals
including dorothy robinson of counsel at
K&L gates and the entire planning
committee at carnegie mellon and at kano
gates please join me in thanking all of
our special guests as well as our
conference organizers there is little
doubt that emerging technologies and
artificial intelligence or at the center
of an ongoing economic and societal
transformation that will no doubt will
continue for decades to come as we
embrace the Internet of Things
unprecedented access to massive amount
of data and the rise of automation and
robotics we're barreling toward a future
run by cyber enabled systems while these
technologies will enhance our comfort
security and quality of life for society
for for all of us their deployment has
had unprecedent consequences for our
workforce our education system
potentially for social justice for
fairness for privacy and many other
aspects of society the effect of
technology on society is not a brand new
concern but as we see these emerging
technologies pervade every aspect of our
lives and disrupt markets and disrupt
industries these issues have become even
more urgent consider for a moment if
new phenomena of tar technology driven
world as data has become a new currency
for business and for technology we're
seeing a dramatic surge in the
collection storage analysis and
monetization of our personal and often
most sensitive data meanwhile the most
cherished attributes of the internet and
the web its speed its reach its openness
and the notion of anonymity are being
used to undermine our democracy and our
civil liberties as AI enhances and
augments and in some cases outpaces
human capabilities human machine
interaction is reimagining the future of
work at the same time the very nature of
employment is involving skill cycles are
shorter than ever before consider for a
moment that according to a recent study
65% of the jobs that generation Z will
perform don't even exist today this will
have dramatic implications for educating
the next generation it's not just a
scale and ubiquity of these advances
that are remarkable the pace of advances
as well as the acceleration of their
economic impact is also unparalleled in
human history as an example it took
landline phones about 45 years to go
from five percent to 50 percent
penetration among US households by
comparison smart phones went from five
percent to 40 percent in about just four
years and that was during a recession
and in 2017 that number reached more
than 77 percent today we're at an
inflection point for the proliferation
of AI robotics and automation as this
innovation moves forward at warp speed
our deployment of ethics our development
of ethics I should say and policy must
keep up
now of course is a time for partners
from across public and private sectors
to come together with effective
communities to ensure that technology is
used to benefit humanity individually of
course as well as the entire society as
the university that has been intimately
involved in the creation and evolution
of artificial intelligence we've
definitely been responsible for some
really groundbreaking innovations but
we've also built an interdisciplinary
culture focused on making sure that
technological progress benefits society
through our partnerships we're K&L gates
as well as our block center for
technology and society which we just
recently launched CMU and our
collaborators are helping to shape the
world in which people policy and
technology are better connected some of
CMU's most passionate partners have been
right here in Pittsburgh which has been
serving as a living laboratory for
technology that is integrated with
society our Mayor Bill Peduto has been
at the forefront of these collaborative
efforts and has established himself as a
national leader in progressive inclusive
and sustainable innovation of American
societies I'm delighted that he's able
to join us today to offer a few words
ladies and gentlemen please join me in
welcoming Pittsburgh Mayor Bill Peduto
[Applause]
Thank You mr. president and thank you to
Carnegie Mellon University and K&L gates
for taking on this issue and being able
to have a discussion and I also want to
thank the person who wrote this speech
for me because it's one of the best
political speeches that I've not going
to read I always try to speak off the
cuff so let me explain what these next
two days mean for policy makers you know
Pittsburgh was an industry leader right
the industrial revolution during World
War two we produced more steel than
Germany in Japan combined and when we
built out this industry in this great
wealth that came to this region it came
at a very heavy cost we had air that was
dangerous to breathe we had water that
was poisonous to drink and we had the
greatest disparity between the people
who worked in those mines and mills and
those that owned and operated them the
greatest disparity in American history
and those were the costs that came with
it and it would take decades and decades
to be able to change that what we did
what Pittsburghers do we created the
first Clean Air Act in American history
and we went about to clean our air we
created public/private partnerships in
order to be able to clean our water and
we organized in those mines and in those
mills and in the process of building
America every Bridge and every
skyscraper we created the middle class
but they came as afterthoughts to the
Industrial Revolution not a component of
the Industrial Revolution
so as we find ourselves today in the
fourth Industrial Revolution we have to
look beyond simply what this technology
can provide the venture capitalists out
of California we have to think about
what it will provide to the people who
live in cities throughout
country we went through decades of
redlining out neighborhoods based upon
race and based upon income we cannot
read line out communities in this new
economy
based on whether or not you have a
cellphone
whether you or not you have credit we
have to be able to make sure everybody
is having that same opportunity and the
technology will help us to expand it we
have to look beyond just what the
technology will do in stark tech
understand how it can minimize negative
effects to the environment and we have
to look and see how it will enhance the
places we call home in Pittsburgh we
call it P for people planet Place and
performance a new metric for a 21st
century not old economics of the 19th
century a quadruple bottom line of being
able to understand how to measure
success and for policymakers it's
absolutely critical because when we look
at the ethics of where AI can take us it
goes beyond purchasing drones for a city
that will come up with issues of privacy
or being able to throw a drone behind a
wall and having somebody have already
have programmed when it takes a human
life at what point then do we start to
think about creating machines and
algorithms that have the ability to take
a human life we are at the forefront of
all of this coming together and it's
coming together so fast but if we don't
plan for the negative consequences in
the beginning
we'll have made the mistake that we made
in the industrial revolution and we will
spend decades trying to solve those
problems
[Applause]
thank you very much bill for your
leadership and for making Pittsburgh be
such an inclusive community I'm happy to
share with you that later this evening
we'll will celebrate the first two
recipients of new professorships funded
through their K&L gates endowment these
recipients exemplify interdisciplinary
nature of these complex issues
the first is illenore Bock who is an
expert of course in our computer science
school while the other Molly write
Stinson investigates past and present
implications of AI and computation on
design and architecture with
appointments in our School of Design and
our school of architecture in addition
the K&L Gates Presidential fellowship
endowed fund will support for
outstanding doctoral students veronica
allant Zachary and Abigail whom you'll
meet later today whose work spans
information systems Computer Science
Engineering public policy and social and
decision science I'm delighted to
congratulate these pioneering scholars
on their prestigious professorship and
scholarship please join me in
congratulating all day awardees
[Applause]
as I mentioned earlier we are truly
fortunate to have K&L gates as our
partner whose generous support will help
us help put us at the center of some of
the most pressing conversations facing
society at this time it is my great
pleasure to introduce Jim Sagar Hall as
global managing partner he serves as a
firm's chief executive officer and
native Pittsburgher so you can tell you
all about the weather
Jim is a board member of the Allegheny
Conference for Community Development
please join me in extending him a warm
welcome to Jim Saget all Thank You
president Johanna and I'm thrilled to be
here it's very exciting event just
terrific to be in the company of so many
brilliant people working on truly
important matters I am pleased and
honored to welcome all of you to the
first inaugural conference of ethics and
artificial intelligence which I am proud
to say is funded by the kano Gates
endowment for ethics and computational
technologies with this initiative we
honor not only our long-standing
relationship with CMU but also the
commitment of both organizations to be
at the forefront in furthering the
understanding of the opportunities and
the challenges presented by the
ever-evolving role of Technology in our
society including the role of artificial
intelligence machine learning and
robotics our law firm has had a long
relationship with CMU over many decades
that relationship has been a source of
tremendous pride for us although our
core missions are different we have
worked together shared civic involvement
and even shared leaders for example one
of my predecessors as Managing Partner
of kano Gates Chuck Queenan is a former
chair of the board at CMU he's currently
an emeritus trustee of the University
continues to provide wisdom and guidance
to both of our organizations with this
conference we have added another
dimension to that relationship as you
know it will be a biennial event and
will be an opportunity that we hope will
stimulate great discussion and important
dialogue you might reasonably ask why is
the field of ethics and intelligence
artificial intelligence important decay
no gates a law firm that's a reasonable
question our firms work and our
footprint is global as well as national
we like to think that we are a leader in
the practice of law as it relates to
technology innovation and development
we're fortunate to represent some of the
leading technology entities in the world
as well as numerous startup companies
that aspire to be in that sphere we care
about what our clients care about and
forward-looking clients everywhere care
about artificial intelligence and its
potential impact on their businesses and
society at large evidence of this is the
fact that our artificial intelligence
practice area now comprises over 80
lawyers the legal app the legal
implications of the application of AI on
our clients is broad deep and
interdisciplinary it will affect
numerous different practice areas for us
and for clients around the world
including mergers and acquisitions
healthcare the protection of
intellectual property employment law and
a host of regulatory issues further the
practice of law itself is undergoing
major shifts in AI increasingly will be
important to how legal services are
delivered to clients we approach what we
do in a forward-looking way with a
forward-looking mindset that's part of
our DNA and that's why we're so excited
to be part of this important discussion
and exchange of ideas all of us know
that advancements and computer related
technologies many of them born of
research here at Carnegie Mellon
University going back to her
Simon and his colleagues will
increasingly bring about profound
changes that affect our society and
humanity in many ways we can see that a
critical dimension to many of the
choices that will have to be made
whether implicitly or explicitly as
technology is developed is the ethical
dimension and this is going to be
important as our policymakers grapple
with difficult issue as time goes on and
as advances are made we all have a stake
in the outcome of these discussions
getting the best minds from across the
relevant fields of study from robotics
to philosophy in between and around to
focus on these problems is essential to
address in these matters efficiently and
ethically in making our gift to fund an
endowment and ethics and computational
technologies we made an investment for
the long term in an area important to us
as a law firm into society at large with
this conference we are pleased to open
this new forum for discussion and
development of the important work of the
speakers and participants welcome and I
hope you enjoy and benefit from the
conference
[Applause]
Thank You President Joe Haney and mr.
Sager doll and Mayor Peduto I'm David
Danks Thurston professor of philosophy
and psychology here at CMU and co-chair
of this event with Eleanor Bosch
currently professor of robotics for
about another two hours at which point
he becomes the inaugural K&L gates
professor of ethics and computational
technologies and it is our great
pleasure to welcome you all to this
inaugural conference on ethics and AI
here in Pittsburgh I want to say a few
words about why this conference needs to
happen now and why it has to have the
format that it has no doubt you're all
well aware that artificial intelligence
has reached fever pitch in society today
thanks to certain companies what they've
done in terms of rushing forth with
deployments in the real world and thanks
to discourse by outstanding
investigative journalists who have
turned the public's attention to these
issues but the people in this room know
something else because many of our
friends who are here from policy makers
to business folks to researchers are
flying around the world at a breakneck
pace now between meetings and other
meetings discussing regulation
discussing entrepreneurship and venture
capital funding to AI discussing the
question of how we engineer ethics into
artificial intelligence systems and all
those meetings are fantastic and must
happen but this meeting has to happen
because there's a fundamental question
that is actually inherently
transdisciplinary what will artificial
intelligence do to our sense of human
identity what will we be in the age that
we can see already on the horizon that's
the fundamental question of identity and
the fundamental question of human
dignity and those are the issues that we
will grapple with during this conference
so we've designed a conference for you
that brings together outstanding
journalists and experts and sets them up
not to talk within Disciplinary confines
but rather to talk in a
transdisciplinary
manner about the core issues of identity
of humanity itself that's a conversation
that we think has to start now
has to repeat over and over again so
that's the conversation that you're part
of and that we're very happy to welcome
you to but enough about the highfalutin
stuff some logistical notes very quickly
you'll notice on all of the tables that
there are cubes that have the schedule
have information about Wi-Fi for those
who are interested in that Twitter
hashtag and so forth throughout the the
conference over the next two days there
will be opportunities for you as members
of the audience to participate in terms
of providing questions for panelists to
answer that will all be done using a
technology refer to a slide Oh an app
and there will be some more information
provided about that as we get to the
first panel the conference is being
live-streamed so if there are people
that you know wanted to participate but
we're unable to be here please let them
know about that
and the conference elements will all
over the coming weeks be rolled out on
the webpage so we encourage you to
continue to look back at that ok back to
the important things this conference as
ela said is about having a conversation
of the ways that technology particularly
AI and robotic technologies are
influencing impacting providing
opportunities and challenges for us
humans for societies for nations for
peoples and in particular we've decided
to organize this conference around four
different sessions each of which is
anchored in a particular human interest
or human value so rather than having a
session on AI and self-driving cars we
have sessions on equity of access and
equity of impact trust policy and
governance and agency and empowerment
which we hope will help to focus the
interdisciplinary and transdisciplinary
and multidisciplinary conversations
around these core human values and
interests so that we can start to make
real progress over the course of the
coming days and so with that said I'd
like to turn things over to ela to
introduce the first session thank you
David
session 1 we're gonna dive right into
this equity of access and they could
impact so let me just say 30 seconds
about that what are the interesting
things about artificial intelligence and
computational technologies writ large is
that they can increase the apparent
productivity of human society they can
allow us to do more they can allow us
new kinds of discoveries new spaces to
in which we can discover and create new
knowledge the challenge with that form
of innovation is of course stemming from
the fact that AI and information itself
has ownership and as a result as you
create new AI technologies new
innovations you have the danger that you
can limit the access to that AI
technology to the few you have the
further danger that you can in fact
augment the wealth of the few through
those very same technologies thus
increasing disparity between the those
who have and those who have not so
fundamentally we have on the one hand
technology that can make the world a
better place
on average the same time we have a
technology that while the average case
might be better
the extrema might be far worse and so
that fundamental challenge in terms of
both access and in terms of how the
world as a whole is impacted by AI
that's the focus of our first session
now each of our sessions is structured
differently so we think you're gonna
enjoy that there are spotlight speakers
there are videos that help to set the
stage and there are panel discussions in
this session we're gonna start with a
video and I'm going to ask to Q that
right away and then I'll introduce the
spotlight speaker to get things started
so let's run with the video please
we really as engineers need to take
responsibility to work on the things
that will make the world a better place
taking responsibility having a research
strategy instead of just going wherever
your curiosity takes you AI and
optimization have very different
strengths than humans do humans are
really good at actually figuring out
what the ins are what the value
judgments are in general how it should
trade-off between different things like
various forms of efficiency and various
forms of fairness but he must think of
them in the context of special cases and
humans are very bad at actually sifting
through all of the possible special
cases of which there are more than the
number of atoms in the universe we
developed this new framework which we
call future match where we take as input
to humans value judgments and then using
AI based simulation and past data we can
actually optimize the policy parameters
as to how do you best achieve those
goals so we're separating the means and
the ends the humans are talking about
ends and the AI is figuring out the
means and I think that this is a very
important separation for the future in
many different areas of AI that's almost
sent home our colleague right here at
Carnegie Mellon University and the
school of computer science now I'm very
pleased to introduce our first speaker
he's gonna set the stage for about 20
minutes and then we're gonna have a
little discussion the comfortable
armchairs in the middle our first
speaker is Sean dae-ho Shobha and I'm
happy to welcome him to the stage
what Shonda is an engineer at RAND
Corporation and he's a professor at the
party ran school his background is
perfect for this his background is in
machine learning optimization control
but he's also branched from machine
learning into health defense and
Technology Policy so from there he's
going to data privacy and accountability
so you notice I mentioned pretty much
all the key words as we look at the way
AI integrates into society
before joining Rand or Sunday was at USC
and indeed got his PhD there in
electrical engineering
and without further ado welcome ocean
day so today we're going to be talking
about equity of access and equity of
impact and how artificial intelligence
mediates transforms affects those two
things I will be suggesting that we look
to the Past look to antiquity to sort of
help us see what's going on in the
future I want us to focus on these two
individuals Plato and Socrates my
contention is that the interaction the
difference is in the way these two
people work kind of sort of pre figures
are complexities the complexity of
dealing with today when it comes to AI
and equity if there is a key takeaway
point from from this conversation I hope
it would be the idea of participatory
equity I will be making the contention
that that should be the foundation of
any successful infrastructure for
ethically aligned what fish or fair AI
now that I have given you the key point
we can all take naps basically back to
Plato so the mental image I have a Plato
is of this undoubted genius but he's
also this guy who's deeply deeply
scarred by one pivotal event in his life
and that's the state sanctioned
execution of his teacher and mentor of
Socrates Socrates Plato reacts to that
event by retreating from the marketplace
of ideas from the from the population
from the community and he sets up this
he sets up this archetype for the
solitary contemplative philosopher and
he he desires you to peers in which
basically the demos the people that he
that he kind of pulls back from sort of
always subject to some philosopher king
and that is the idea what a fair society
is and it does is without engaging with
the people at all he just designed this
from
now contrast this to how Socrates does
inquiry he engages deeply and very very
critically with the community he's
engaged he's around when he asked when
he has to answer the simple question
what is wisdom now he doesn't get his
answer he doesn't get a definite I'm
definitely to answer from that question
from an interaction but at least he can
claim some defense against the biases
that his personal perspective
necessarily brings to that conversation
think about how these two men might have
thought about the questions that lay
before us today
the idea of equity what is equity and
how do our giri's make decision-making
artifacts interact with equity Aristotle
makes an appearance in discussions of
equity also but we won't focus on him
today back in the day a few months ago I
was introduced as done as an engineer of
fairness that's a little bit of a
paradoxical title engineers have this
image of being objective precise
analysts while fairness is this very
contextual very socially defined very
fuzzy concept that slippery to define I
argue that any any discussion of
artificial intelligence and equity is
going to be doomed to this compress of
opposite qualities it used to be that
when we talked about AI equity people
sneer at us they'll say things like well
what is equity in the same way that
Pontius Pilate probably asked what is
truth and typical conversations about AI
policies they were focused on these
future looking scenarios this Terminator
scenarios these are existential crises
and I would argue that that that focus
that's a product of a privileged
perspective a perspective they cannot
imagine the problems of AI affecting us
today they have to look to the future to
see to imagine things that go wrong now
that is probably a lazy argument so I
offer a reconciliation so here we have
parking
along pushing that line of inquiry let
me offer a reconciliation by observing
that questions of AI equity and AI
safety existential safety concerns they
actually share common wheat for example
they are concerned with value alignment
by value alignment I mean how do we
design algorithms that that support
society defined norms they also share
the problem of explained ability in the
in the interest of X of procedural
transparency we would like to be able to
derive stable robust meaningful
explanations from the algorithmic
decision making artifacts but let's
focus on equity when you focus on equity
there are there are there are these
definitional problems there are these
issues these are perceived that picture
in the definition of equity and it's a
great thing that we now have examples
that in spite of the arbitrary in spite
of definition of problems they're able
to demonstrate examples of algorithms
violating socially defined equity norms
these examples have done as deep and and
huge service of kind of sort of
challenging that deep slumber of settle
opinion that algorithms are necessarily
fair and infallible in fact we have
researchers now saying that any any
technological design necessarily embed
ethical decisions necessarily embed
values either implicitly or explicitly
when we talk about AI equity with those
conversations turn on how those values
align with society defined expectations
of fairness the first is a street bump
example the second is a compensation
division and the third is insurance
price in the last two examples were sort
of where the result of ProPublica is
explorations let's try to examine how
bias is my seep into our supposedly
objective infallible algorithms we are
probably familiar with how a I systems
are designed this is really design phase
a programming
is a training phase and a testing phase
but right here in the design of an
algorithmic artifact to make a decision
we have situations where we have framing
artifacts framing effects when you
design a system to make decisions and
you focus any frame it as an
optimization on predictive accuracy it
shouldn't be surprising when you have
fairness fairness problems with that
with that design
besides the the actual framing effects
in the design you have inputs that are
used to design the systems these usually
consist of data and assumptions at least
in models that is to come machine
learning models you know all the AI
models they relied more on rules and
assumptions explicit rules and
assumptions but even in these inputs you
have this problem and I'm using terms
from behavioral economics to help us
maybe train this better we have this
Pirlo of naive realism where the model
assumes that the data it give it's it's
able to see is a complete contextual
representation of the real world so you
can imagine a model trained on a subset
of the population assuming that the
general population to which to going to
be applied looks like that training set
that's a form of naive realism or you
can imagine an algorithm trying to make
inferences about people's networks based
on just social media links assuming that
social media links represent the full
state of connections in the real world
that's a form of naive realism we also
have this issue of anchoring biases
statistical models they tend to
basically anchor on examples they've
seen in the past this is an example of a
generalization error problem and so by
anchoring on those examples in the
future when it's presented with things
it's not familiar with you have these
anchors that can sort of help sometimes
they help sometimes they're not so good
the last part where biases can seep in
isn't the outcomes so we have this issue
we might call outcome bias or automation
bias where we assume that the process
the outcome of our decision-making
artifact characterized the quality of
the of the decision-making artifact it's
just like the the key example here might
be saying well a broken
clock is correct twice a day if you
observe it only have those two points of
the day you think it's it's working
perfectly but you're not thinking about
the process by which is getting those
decisions you're not questioning whether
that's correct or not so this is just a
framing I might suggest for how we might
think about how biases in equity CPM to
grade make decision-making like
artifacts let's try to be I'm going to
try to present two examples to case
studies where we can examine how an
algorithm might have to deal with equity
concerns the first is the use of
algorithms in criminal justice example
applications of the use of algorithms as
reflected in a compass report it is the
use of algorithms for setting bills and
for sentencing it used to be that
compass was mainly for setting bail
increasingly there was a feature creep
where it was increasingly used for
sentencing now the frame I'm going to
use to talk about this case to design
exam is something I'm hoping we can take
away from this conversation every time
you think about algorithms in
decision-making which you think about
the problem is trying to solve in this
case bills bill setting a sentencing but
we should also be explicit about the
guiding norms the equity norms that
decision making artifact is subject to
in the context of criminal justice I
would argue that we have at least two
norms the equal protection norm
guaranteed by the US Constitution at
least in the United States and you might
also argue for the due process norm
guaranteed by the Fifth Amendment rights
the second example the second case study
the second domain would be algorithms
not insurance insurance represents this
it solves this social social function of
safeguarding people from catastrophic
risk and so it's not surprising that
insurers might want to use algorithms to
help them make their make their
decisions more accurate more fair
example applications example problems
here are the problems of rate setting
and underwriting rate certain is just
really about setting the price of an
insurance premium
underwriting is kind of sort of gauging
the risk the risk tranches for people
who are supposed to be insured now what
would be the insurance the guiding norm
in the situation this is a bit more
complicated and I'd argue that the
actuarial
this body of the United States says well
your insurance prices should be actually
fair ie
the cost of an insurance premium should
reflect on the lying risk of the person
but then we have these issues when we
start asking for universal health care
mandate universal insurance mandate and
have to worry about affordability being
part of the norms here now in a market
setting that might be a problem these
are questions we'll have to tease out as
we as we think about equity going
forward let's try to use these case
studies to tease out more general ideas
well the very first idea or the very
first theme is that equity norms and
necessarily context-specific that's an
almost obvious statement but that
obvious statement kind of undermines our
expectation that maybe there is this
prescriptive mathematical definition of
equity that we just need to impose on
algorithms to make them fair that's
probably not going to happen and we can
actually add more to we can actually add
more context more complexity to this to
this issue of the existence of
prescriptive equity norms work by I hope
I'm pronouncing that name properly shoe
- / and crime burg Emily Nathan they are
addressing they are identifying what we
might call weak impossibility theorems
that if you have a set of a set of
mathematically defined equity norms that
you would hope your decision-making
artifact respect in this case group
calibration equality of negative force
positive or false negative rate equality
or false positive rate there is
something inherently incompatible in
trying to achieve all three equity norms
and conversations a few a few months a
few weeks ago at the fat ml conference
extended this to any collection of
equity mathematically defined equity
norms trying to satisfy more than three
and three or more is income is
impossible we can call that on a weak
impossibility theorem now you might hear
this and think well since I can have it
all
let me just have let me have my users
vote to decide which is and which ones
are important
but then we run into impossibility
theorem is the stronger impossibility
theorems by Kenneth arrow Bieber dance
after tweet saying essentially it's
impossible to reasonably aggregate
Collective normative preferences alright
so that's the second theme the third
team I'm trying to have been trying to
develop over the past year or so or two
thinking about this is this framing of
allocation problems distribution
problems as entitlement programs versus
market programs we can think about it as
a spectrum entitlement distribution
programs the distribution problems in
which there are clear equity norms
guiding the decision process the
distribution distributed decision
process normative clarity usually means
that there is some law some regulation
and everybody accepts that determines
how fair our decision is you can think
about the example of United States
criminal justice you have the public
good law enforcement that's being
distributed to the public under the
normative guidelines of equal protection
and due process but we also have what we
might think of as market programs market
distribution programs are just
distribution programs where equity norms
play little or no role and the
distributive action is determined
largely by the intersection of demand or
supply now let's try to figure out
questions that come up from this in the
entitlement programs you have the
question of are the norms necessarily
equitable and if they are not equitable
are there remedies for it social
movements like black lives matter and
civil rights movements they are
essentially challenges to the equity
norms they rule in equity norms at the
time and we have the same essentially
that legality is not really a question
of justice the question of power and we
switch over to the market session you
have this issue of there is a trade-off
between the accuracy the efficiency of
the market and the imposition of equity
norms if we try to make a market fair
accordance on the equity norms you can
often impose a
deadweight cost what is essentially dead
wood cost
the question becomes who gets to bear
that burden and how big is that burden
that sounds theoretical highfalutin in
concrete terms you can think about it in
terms of the mark the insurance market
in health insurance if you have
universal mandate who gets to bear the
cost of that increasing in risk just
because you have universal mandate less
controversially initially in auto
insurance market who gets to bear that
cost those are questions we have to
tackle with we have to grapple with if
we really care about equity in the
decision-making systems all right I feel
like I've been a bit negative about the
prospect of algorithmic equity let's try
to see if I can pull out more positive
vision from the rubble
we've I've been poking holes in the idea
that you can actually define press
creative equity enormous mathematically
and impose them on your algorithms and
even if such a thing existed you will
still need a buy-in of your subjects of
your users that is not easy to to to
maintain to receive in a dictatorial
technocracy so this suggests that maybe
we should be thinking more about
participate reversions participatory
models of AI equity basically these will
be models in which your users which
constantly
query your users for equity concerns
when we talk about diversity in the rank
this is the diversity point you knew it
was coming so whatever when we talk
about diversity in the ranks of
algorithmic designers we are not just
pleading special circumstances it's
precisely because by having more design
more diversity in the rank of designers
you're pulling in more social
perspectives to inform the design
process but even diversity diversify is
not enough because if you think about it
algorithms are always necessarily going
to act well generally going to affect
more people than are being represented
in the designer class
so what you're going to need is
something that allows for for more
participation from wider groups and we
can sharpen this point by observing that
equity challenges equity concerns
they're distributed form of knowledge
there is no single controlling group
that's ever going to be able to
coordinate the transmission and
accommodation of equity challenges so we
need more participation basically we
need more more most Socrates and fewer
Plato's designing from from isolation we
need people who are going to go out
there and do the messy work of engaging
with the subject and this is where I'm
reminded again of shoulder shoulders
work on the Allegheny County child
welfare system it's really good work
which is why I'm talking about it now
besides the participatory model we might
want to think about instead of
prescriptive norms we might want to
think about infrastructures for imposing
for enabling and designing equity into
algorithmic decision-making systems this
is kind of sort of the gdpr route
instead of trying to impose norm as you
impose it like you define an
infrastructure that enables good
behavior to to happen now you might want
to ask ourselves what are the key the
minimal key components of such an
infrastructure I want to argue for three
or three or four fluency we need more
fluency in the principles of equity so
the economist Peyton Jung put it this
way equity principles these norms I've
been going on about and the mathematical
definitions of these norms they are
really just instruments they're not ends
in themselves they're just imposed in an
algorithm they are really instrument by
which society kind of sort of
adjudicates equity problems distributive
problems especially when efficient in
market efficiency fails as a as a
criterion now if we are not fluent in
the language of equity principles
they're going to have problems properly
adjudicated and responding to equity
concerns
the second one under which I'll combine
it to transparency and dissent I think
primarily it's about dissent you need
any implementation any algorithmic
implementation to have basically settled
avenues for for enabling dissent for
collecting dissent from the users part
of that dissent procedure will probably
require transparency at all the norms
governing the area throughout the domain
and thirdly I think this is the part
that feels especially in privacy
conversations you need methods for
accountable redress you need to be able
to have institutions be able to make and
keep promises you need incentives to
allow that to happen usually at least
according to GDP GDP GDP are basically
says or the way to do that is by having
these steep fines and I'm inclined to
agree because we have a history of data
breaches that have that has not abated
in spite of the small fines we've been
having so far these are the ideas I have
out there I I will admit that my
conversation has been from a very
allocated distribution perspective I I
want to acknowledge Kate Crawford
perspective that besides allocated
problems you have representational harms
that come from using algorithms in
society windows allocate renders
when algorithms that have that will
present the proper distribution and
society this disparate distributions of
society are now responsible for shaping
our preferences what does that mean long
term that's all I have for you
[Applause]
thank you
now we get to relax and talk take any
chair as long just one in the middle -
that's like a fair allocation problem
that's right so fascinating talk we have
a few questions we're gonna ask
everybody but I have to drill into what
you said first okay first of all you
know when you talked about weak and
strong impossibility there was a point
there that I think it's important to
reiterate for the audience so I want to
ask you to build out a little bit
because this idea that mathematically
achieving a computational way of
including the norms of equity such that
the computer system itself the robot the
AI system can execute and guarantee that
mm-hmm what I heard you say is that
that's essentially impossible yeah I
mean I mean we can all we can all talk
about okay we want equal we can oh wait
we can make arguments for certain equity
principles to be enforced in algorithms
but at some point a group is going to
argue and see actually the outcome on
our end is is violate what we think is
fair you're going to have to accommodate
that non theoretical that very practical
messy equity concern and that probably
means moving away from mathematically
precise definitions of equity and trying
to kind of engage with them I I think
the judgment hand he put it this way he
said equity concerns
well equity is really just about the the
the uncomfortable accommodation of
conflict to the society trying to do
that in a precise mathematical way might
not be a robust solution long term this
reminds me of talking to urban designers
who say there's this thing called the
wicked problem you can't optimize
because this is a social challenge
exactly and this also reminds me of the
defense argument this says we'll make
the perfect robot soldier argument
against which is no actually even war is
social we don't optimize it
quantitatively yep yep well so this is
interesting if it's the case that we
can't actually hope for an AI system
that will make the world equitable by
the very nature of how its programmed
then you talked about participatory
equity which I love except when I look
at this
like Facebook er AdWords on Google what
I see is participatory systems and what
I see in those systems is since no
system is equitably perfect so to speak
people find a way to hack them yep and
then use their own asymmetric levers of
power there to hack the very
participatory system you created to do
things like throw say I don't know an
election so that's not funny but ability
so I would argue that maybe the the the
issue is probably mechanism design
learning to to put in incentives and in
platforms that allow that allow for this
type of for correcting for these types
of evolutionary behaviors over time
trying to a priority design a perfect
system that's like you're saying it's
not going to happen so it's about insane
structural incentives creating an
infrastructure for for for modifying
them over time so then here's my fear I
totally get that we're gonna make
systems we'll make them as as good as we
can
people will misuse them they're only bad
actors and we're going to respond we're
gonna have a rapid reaction to that but
here's my concern the AI systems we're
talking about are inherently
accumulating and concentrating power and
knowledge which means the bad actors
ability to negatively influence reality
it's big and only bigger next year and
the year after here so it seems to me by
the time we catch them the crimes get
worse before we do the redress or the
things so don't we have this weird
runaway problem yes is it so my so I
this these are problems I think about
every day and I talk about with my with
fellow researchers at Rand and one of my
fellow research because I dislike the
solution right I don't see a way around
it one of my fellow researchers rant
Walsman he argues that the way to
address this is to have adversarial
reaction so the first person the bad
actors do something like flooding for
the net with with Reznick fake news and
the solution is for the good actors to
flood the net with resonant true-true
News and the idea is how to is basically
this back and forth between between
actors I see that as a runaway situation
yeah but thinking of solutions is hard
so that's really scares me that's a good
way to start the conference because
we're clearly into the conference so let
me jump on my extreme level of fear now
that I have to the three questions we're
hoping to ask everybody because this
gives us a neat thread to push
throughout the whole conference I think
you answered one of them already but I'm
getting ahead of myself
the first question I really want to
narrow your view and unfortunately cause
you to prognosticate a little bit into
the future I want to look at the next
ten years hmm and I want to ask the
question what is the thing you're most
excited about visa Vai and equity what
is it what is something you can imagine
that that's actually doable the next ten
years where AI can actually help with
questions of equity was a good one we
didn't share these with the speakers
ahead of time so I think we already seen
this happening maybe ten years is too
far out the issue of credit allocation
credit scoring for thin file for thin
flour subjects people who don't have
large records in large formal records in
the economic sectors so this would be
like people in developing countries poor
people the ability to use artificial
intelligence to I tried to use the term
algorithm intelligence as often as I can
the ability to use machine learning
methods to learn about credit score
about credit worthiness from all the
sources of data seems to me extremely
powerful well if if properly applied and
properly supervised because you can also
use the type of scoring mechanism for
things like the China the Chinese
approach of social scoring but just
enabling better credit to people in
poorer situations he's a huge
transformative fit I think and I love
that answer because it also brings into
the play the whole question of
developing world and ways in which
developing world may access what we're
talking about so the second question is
the exact opposite again
limiting ourselves to ten years or so
what is it that most
keeps you up at night in terms of equity
and AI mmm mine don't sleep regularly so
you know I tend to avoid projects
involve in heart defense because it
makes me really anxious and the question
of deterrence in a world in which we
have a I enabled weapons makes me
worried and worse than that it's not
just the existence of the weapons that
makes me worried its take is the
differences in the culture the cultures
deploying those weapons if you think
about the Chinese the Chinese our
approach to defense in the American
approach to defense you have basically
China seeming to be more trusting of
just wholesale fully automated weapons
and you have United States doctrine say
something to the effect that will always
have humans in the loop that that that
makes sense from that seems comfortable
comforting from a unilateral perspective
but imagine a situation in which a
country has human loop for all the
autonomous systems and the other country
just doesn't care that seems to have
deterrent implications that are
difficult to think about so lack of
parity may actually force a good actor
to become less good yep indeed last
question for you is an interesting
future in question that's kind of
navel-gazing about this conference so
imagine we're here 15 years from now
having this conference mmm how will it
look or feel different because of AI I
assume most people would not actually be
here would have bots in telepresence
always be talking to a set of screens
here yeah III like this idea and maybe I
mean I'm trying to imagine how that
would apply in a conference setting I
like this idea of our clock on traumas
extended mind I feel like most of us
will be more invested in the tools that
enable us to engage with the world and
so maybe we'll have augmented brains of
some sort that make us faster thinkers I
always think about how to think faster
how to think more creatively and I
imagine that artificial intelligence
will probably enabled
the future so cognitive orthotics for us
all maybe yeah excellent well thank you
so much for joining us wonderful speech
[Applause]